JOINING US FOR OUR BUSINESS AND
PROFESSIONS HEARING WE HAVE
THREE BILLS ON THE CALENDAR
TODAY AND THERE ARE. ADDITIONAL
FOR THESE THREE OF COURSE AT
THE CAN RECENTLY AMENDED FOR
POLICY DISCUSSIONS THAT WERE
NOT PREVIOUSLY HEARD IN THIS
COMMITTEE SO THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FOR JOINING US WE KNOW
THAT KNOWS THE PRESENCE OF.
MEMBERS ON BOTH SIDES THE ARMY
BEGIN WITH FILE ITEM NUMBER ONE
WHICH IS ASSEMBLY BILL TWELFTH
SIXTY FOUR BY. ASSEMBLY MEMBER
PETRIE-NORRIS AND WE ALSO
NOTICE THE ABSENCE OF A QUORUM
SO BE ACTING AS A SUB COMMITTEE
SO PLEASE FEEL FREE 2% WHENEVER
YOU'RE READY. OF THE FOUR. THIS
BILL CLARIFIES BAKED TELL
HEALTH CARE LIES IN ORDER TO
REDUCE MEDICALLY UNNECESSARY
BARRIERS TO. TELEHEALTH
PRESCRIBING. AS YOU MAY RECALL
THE ORIGINAL FOCUS AS OUR BILL
WAYS IMPROVING ACCESS TO BIRTH
CONTROL AND ADDRESSING THIS IN
THE REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH CARE
SPACE. WE'VE BEEN WORKING
REALLY CLOSELY WITH OUR PARTNER
AND THE BILL'S SPONSOR PLANNED
PARENTHOOD ON THIS BILL. AS WE
MOVE THROUGH THE LEGISLATIVE
PROCESS IT BECAME CLEAR THAT
THIS ISSUE IS RELEVANT NOT
SIMPLY IN THE REPRODUCTIVE
HEALTH CARE SPACE BUT WHEN IT
COMES TO PRESCRIBING MORE
BROADLY. AND SO AS A RESULT
WE'VE I WORK WITH OUR COALITION
PARTNERS TO AMEND THE BELL. AND
DADDY AMENDMENTS HAS MOVED THE
CODE SECTION FROM TWENTY TO
FORTY TWO DOT TWO TO TWENTY TWO
FORTY TWO. AND SPECIFICALLY AB
TWELVE SIXTY FOUR SIMPLY
CLARIFIES THAT A SYNCHRONOUS
VISIT IS NOT ALWAYS REQUIRED
FOR TELEHEALTH PRESCRIBING.
PROVIDED THAT THE ALTERNATIVE
MACINNES AND- MEETS THE
ACCEPTED STANDARD OF CARE. AS
WE ALL KNOW NEW TECHNOLOGIES
HAVE CHANGED SO MUCH OF WHAT WE
DO AND HOW WE DO IT IT'S ALSO
OPEN UP OPPORTUNITIES FOR US TO
HEALTH CARE ALL ACROSS THE
STATE BECAUSE LAWMAKERS IT SAT.
INCUMBENT UPON US TO ENSURE
THAT WE ARE WORKING WITH OUR
MEDICAL PROFESSIONALS TO. TAKE
ADVANTAGE OF THOSE
OPPORTUNITIES AND EXPAND ACCESS
TO CARE WHERE POSSIBLE. I'VE
GOT TO AS SUPPORTERS HERE WITH
ME AND THAT WE ARE PLEASED TO
ANSWER. ANY QUESTIONS THAT YOU
MAY HAVE. PERFECT THANK YOU
WELCOME. MY RIBS AND WITH
PLANNED PARENTHOOD AFFILIATES A
CALIFORNIA CHILE JUST IF YOU
HAVE ANY QUESTIONS ABOUT THE
BILL. GOOD MORNING AMY TO
REMOVE THE CALIFORNIA MEDICAL
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT OF THE
BILL IN QUESTION. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH ANY ADDITIONAL
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC WISHING
TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT. THING THEN
ANY MEMBERS OF PUNK WISHING TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION SIGNAL
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC WISHING
TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION ANY
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM ANY
COMMITTEE MEMBERS AT THIS TIME.
SEEING NONE SEVEN TWENTY WAS
TOO CLOSE. THANK YOU AS I SAID
SIMPLY ASK FOR YOUR CONTINUED
SUPPORT FOR A BI TWELVE SIXTY
FOUR THANK YOU WONDERFUL AND
WILL TAKE UP THIS ITEM WHEN WE
HAVE ESTABLISHED A QUORUM.
THANK YOU SO MUCH THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. THEN WE'LL- MOVE ON
TO THE FOLLOWING TWO BILLS. ON
FILE AND THEN WE'LL BEGIN WITH
FOLLOWED A NUMBER TWO FALL BY
PHONE NUMBER THREE WHICH- ALSO
PRESENT ON BEHALF OF SENATOR
GLAZERS OR TURN THIS OVER TO
OUR VICE CHAIR. NEXT UP IS FILE
AND NEVER TO AB FIFTEEN TWENTY
NINE BY CHAIR LOW. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH COLLEAGUES AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS THIS A BILL
IS WITH RESPECT ENSURING THAT
WE HAVE THE INDUSTRY OF
CANNABIS. THE MANUFACTURERS AND
OTHERWISE FOCUS ON THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF UNIVERSAL
SYMBOL MAKE SURE THAT WE ARE
COMPLYING WITH THE RULES AND
REGULATIONS ACCORDINGLY
RESPECTFULLY ASK PRIVATE.
MISTER CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS ANY
JENKINS ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA CANNABIS INDUSTRY
ASSOCIATION AND CALCRAFT VERY
PROUD CO SPONSORS OF THIS BILL
WHEN I THINK THE AUTHOR FOR HIS
WILLINGNESS TO HELP RESOLVE
THIS ISSUE THIS IS PARTICULARLY
IMPORTANT FOR THE CANNABIS
INDUSTRY. PARTICULARLY IN LIGHT
OF SOME OF THE RECENT MEDIA
REPORTS ABOUT ILLNESSES
INVOLVING BAY PENS THESE ARE
NOT INVOLVING COMPLAINT FATE
PENS AND HAVING THAT UNIVERSAL
SYMBOL CLEARLY VISIBLE ON THE
CARTRIDGE WILL ENSURE THAT
CONSUMERS KNOW THAT THE PRODUCT
THEY ARE CONSUMING AND SAFE SO
WEAK ENCOURAGE AYE VOTE TODAY
AND THANK YOU. THANK YOU
NATIONAL IN THIS IS IN SUPPORT.
GOOD MORNING MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS TRACY STEVEN ON BEHALF
OF NOR CAL CANNABIS ALSO ON
BEHALF OF NATURAL LIFE SCIENCES
AND SHASTA COUNTY GROWERS IN
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. TIM LYNCH ON BEHALF OF PAX
LABS WERE SUPPORT OF THE BILL
THANK YOU. ANDREAS I MADE AS ON
BEHALF OF MARXIAN CARE CANNABIS
SOLUTIONS AND SUPPORT THANK YOU.
NICOLE WATERMAN ON BEHALF OF
BLOOM FARMS TERROR ATTACK
REGULATED SOLUTIONS AND NEW
TROPIC IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU.
BURGER MURPHY ON BEHALF OF WEED
MAPS IN STRONG SUPPORT THANK
YOU. ALICIA PRIEGO BEHALF OF
EASE IN SUPPORT THANK. MAX WHAT
WAS ON BEHALF OF FLOW CARLIN
SUPPORT THANK YOU. EMILY HERE'S
ON BEHALF OF CALIFORNIA CANVAS
MANUFACTURERS ASSOCIATION IN
CUBA CONFECTIONS IN SUPPORT
THANK. RAND MARTIN ON BEHALF OF
KHALIFA AND BLACK BIRD
LOGISTICS AND SUPPORT THANK YOU
THANK YOU CONDITIONALLY MRS IN
SUPPORT SEEING NONE WITNESSES
IN OPPOSITION. SEEING NONE A
RAVE ACT COMMITTEE MEMBERS IF
THERE ANY QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
MISS LOW JUST QUICK COMMENT TO
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
BRINGING THE BILL I THINK IT
SAID. IS THIS IS A GOOD THING
TO DO I DO WANT TO MAKE A
COMMENT ABOUT OF THE SAFETY OF
VAPING I THINK THE EVIDENCE
RIGHT NOW IS VERY UNCLEAR.
EXACTLY OF WHAT ABOUT VAPING
AND WHICH VAPING PRODUCTS ARE
LEADING TO A RAPID A VERY RAPID
RISE IN RESPIRATORY ILLNESSES
SOME OF WHICH HAVE RESULTED IN
A VERY SADLY AND- DEATHS OF. OF
PEOPLE BOTH YOUNG AND OLD AND
SO THIS IS A TOPIC THAT I THINK
WE NEED TO PAY A LOT OF
ATTENTION TO NOT LET IT FESTER
AND TO. HOPEFULLY WE'LL FIND
OUT EXACTLY WHAT THE CAUSE IS
SECOND IN IN SHORT ORDER
CLEARLY SOMETHING THAT IS
FOCUSED IN. AND AROUND VAPING
AND- YOU KNOW IF IT WERE ME I
WOULD BE STAYING AWAY FROM THE
PRODUCT RIGHT. THANK YOU THE
SHOW MEMBERS WISHING THE
QUESTION OR COMMENT. SEEING
NONE MISTER CHAIRMAN LOOK CLOSE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH I JUST WANT
TO ECHO THE SAME TYPE OF
SENTIMENTS ALSO FROM A SIMILAR
BLOOM IT IS THE MOST IMPORTANT
OF THIS COMMITTEE PARTICULARLY
FUNDS CONSUMER PROTECTION AND
HAVE THE OUTSTANDING ISSUES IS
OF SIGNIFICANT CONERN AND
WOULD LIKE TO PUBLICLY ALSO ASK
FOR THE ENGAGEMENT OF INDUSTRY
TO JOIN US IN THOSE EFFORTS ON
MAKING SURE THAT WE CAN
IDENTIFY THIS ACCORDINGLY SO
SHOW AN ECHO THOSE COMMENTS
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR A VOTE
WITH RESPECT TO THIS BILL IN
FRONT OF US. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR WE JUST ESTABLISH A
QUORUM TO COOK THESE CALL THE
ROLL. HELLO. BROWN ARAMBULA.
BLOOM CHEN. CHIU CUNNINGHAM.
EGGMAN FONG. GIPSON GLORIA.
GRAYSON HOLDEN. IRWIN MCCARTY.
MEDINA MULLIN OBERNOLTE TING.
THE BILL. THE MOTION A SECOND
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. AB
FIFTEEN TWENTY NINE MOTION IS
SEVEN MINUTES TO BE CONCURRED
IN LOW WELL I BROKE UP I AM
REGULAR BLOOM. IN MY CHEN CHEN
AYE CHIU CUNNINGHAM EGGMAN FONG
FUNG NINE GIPSON. GLORIA OR AYE
GRAYSON GRAYSON AYE HOLDEN
IRWIN. RELY MCCARTY MEDINA
MEDINA AYE MULLIN OBERNOLTE
REALTY I TING. THAT IS TEN
VIRTUALLY ROLE OPEN FOR
ADDITIONAL MEMBERS OUT ON WILL
GO TO OUR FINAL ITEM FILER AND
THREE SB SIX OF 6% GLAZER THE
CHAIR WILL BE PRESENTING THIS
BILL THANK YOU VERY MUCH
COMMITTEE MEMBERS AND
PRESENTING ON BEHALF OF SENATOR
GLAZER ON TECHNICAL AMENDMENTS
TO THREE. SPORTS ON THE
DEPARTMENT CONSUMER AFFAIRS
RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL THE BILL.
WHEN MRS IN SUPPORT DENNIS
COVERS ROAD DEPUTY DIRECTOR FOR
LEGISLATIVE AFFAIRS FOR THE
DEPARTMENT OF CONSUMER AFFAIRS
HERE FOR ANY TECHNICAL
QUESTIONS. ADDITIONAL WITNESSES
IN SUPPORT HEALING YOU TO THE
EXECUTIVE OFFICER OF THE BOARD
OF VOCATIONAL NURSING AND
PSYCHIATRIC TECHNICIANS HERE
FOR ANY QUESTIONS YOU MIGHT
HAVE THANK YOU ADDITIONALLY
DECISION SUPPORT SEEN ON
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION SEEING
NOT BRING ABOUT COMMITTEE
MEMBERS ANYONE WISHING ASK A
QUESTION OR COMMENT. THE
NUMBERS CHAIR LIKE CLOSE
RESPECTFULLY ASK FAVOR. IS NOT
A MOTION AND A SECOND CLERK
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. SB SIX
ZERO SIX MOTIONSTO PASS LOW
BUT I BROWN BRO I REGULAR BLOOM
BUT MY CHEN CHEN AYE CHIU
CUNNINGHAM EGGMAN FONG FONG AYE
GIPSON GLORIA COLOR I GRAYSON
GRAYSON AYE HOLDEN. IRWIN WHEN
I MCCARTY. MEDINA MEDINA AYE
MULLIN OBERNOLTE OKAY I TING
TING AYE. THAT IS ELEVEN ZERO A
LEAD ROLE OPEN FOR ADDITIONAL
MEMBERS TO ADD ON. FILE ITEM
ONE I'D ENTERTAIN A MOTION.
MOVE ON THE STROLL NOTICE
SECOND MY MISTER TANK PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. AB TWELVE SIXTY
FUR MOTION IS SEVEN MINUTES TO
BE CONCURRED IN LOW. BUT I
BROWN. RENOVATING ARAMBULA
BLOOM WHEN I CHEN CHEN AYE CHIU
CUNNINGHAM EGGMAN FONG FONG AYE
GIPSON. GLORIA GLORIA AYE
GRAYSON GRAYSON AYE HOLDEN
IRWIN. WHEN I MCCARTY MEDINA
MEDINA AYE MULLIN OBERNOLTE
OBERNOLTE NINE TING TING AYE.
THAT IS TEN VOTE TO LEAVE IT
OPEN FOR ADDITIONAL MEMBERS AT
ALL
. YES IMAGES THAT LEAVE THE-
ROLE OPEN FOR ADDITIONAL OF
FIVE MINUTES FOR MEMBERS TO ADD
ON. THEY WERE LIKE THAT. YEAH
.
THANK YOU. MOVIE CHANNEL.
NATALIE. BUT YOU'RE RIGHT. I
WILL BE HERE WE GO YEAH HI.
POLICY MENDOZA PROCEDURES. THE
FACT THAT. YEAH THEY ARE AND
THAT'S EXACTLY WHAT WE'RE. OR
BILLS NEXT YEAR. YEAH. OKAY.
YEAH
. I WILL WILL BE. YEAH BUT
I WELL. HELLO. YES ALL RIGHT
GET. RIGHT THANK YOU. OKAY
RIGHT YEAH. FOCUSING A LOT
CLOSER THAN. JUST GIVE ME A
CALL FOR TOMORROW. YOU SEE TO
PROTECT YOURSELF
. YOU'RE GOING
TO CALL. AB TWELVE SIXTY FOUR
FINAL VOTE IS FOURTEEN ZERO.
MAYBE FIFTEEN TWENTY NINE FINAL
VOTERS FIFTEEN TO ZERO. SB SIX
ARE SIX FINAL VOTE FIFTEEN TO
ZERO THANK YOU WE ORDERED